mobilisation dans l'internet français
avec leur ordinateur près de 160 mille
personnes ont signé cette pétition pour
dire non à un projet de loi du
gouvernement sur l'économie numérique
un texte qui selon eux ne remet en cause
la liberté d'expression car à l'avenir
des entreprises privées seraient chargés
de surveiller tout ce qui se passe sur
internet
on demande simplement que sur internet
ça se passe comme dans la vie normale
sûr que si je fais quelque chose de
répréhensible ce soit la police qui
m'arrêtent la police qui fasse la la
police et puis si je veux être jugé
c'est un juge indépendant et impartial
et que ce soit pas des intermédiaires
techniques des groupes privés qui soit
chargée de ce genre d'opération de ce
genre de mission le projet de loi
demande notamment aux fournisseurs
d'accès ces opérateurs privés qui
permettent de se connecter à internet de
surveiller et de filtrer tous les
fichiers informatiques qui passe par
leur réseau une mission impossible selon
lui c'est un peu comme si vous me
demandiez de mettre un gendarme derrière
chaque internaute et c'est comme si l'on
demandait à la poste de vérifier le
contenu de chaque lettre en ligne de
mire le piratage de la musique sur
internet des chansons copiés
illégalement et échanger gratuitement
entre internautes
l'industrie du disque réclame une
nouvelle législation pour enrayer un
phénomène qui entame ses profits en
france les ventes de cd ont chuté
l'année dernière de près de 15%
cette façon de télécharger gratuitement
de la musique c'est une façon de
supprimer les artistes de demain en
supprimant des contrats aujourd'hui en
2003 on a signé trois à quatre fois
moins de nouveaux contrats d'artistes
que l'année d'avant
la loi sur l'économie numérique répond à
une directive européenne
un dossier devenu sensible son adoption
au parlement a été reporté après les
élections régionales monsieur santini